yeah thank you everyone for coming today
yeah like I mentioned we're gonna be
talking about how to build a a I powered
pet detector in Visual Studio code and a
long time Visual Studio code we're gonna
be using some other tech techniques such
as like a
tensorflow Azure machine learning we're
also gonna be using some Jupiter
notebooks so all that cool stuff so I'm
just gonna go through how we can do all
that super easily so just the like you
mentioned I'm Geoffrey me so I'm a
program manager here at Microsoft and I
specifically work on the data science
and AI tools inside vs code so if you
ever use Python and OBS code added data
science in vs code and it made you feel
sad feel free to reach out to me so I
can help fix that you can also find me
our twitter at Jeffrey underscore mu and
my emails on there as well so being the
newest one of the newest people to my
team I have like the least number of
followers and if everyone on Twitter so
if you wanna help me out you can follow
me and a tiny bit about myself I love
dogs which is why I'm doing this like
pet detector demo for dog like dog and
cat breeds and I also want Python the
language not the snake I don't want to
keep it like animal theme so I just want
to get started with like a quick demo of
what we're actually building today and
like how we'll all look so I'm just
gonna exit out this and move into my
favorite editor yes code so I actually
have the service running up already on
the cloud as I deployed earlier today
and we're gonna be testing it like a
quick dog breed so I have this like
really cool website I found instead of
just doing like google image search
there's just like dog API that just
gives you a random image of a dog breed
so does anyone have like a dog breed
that they like beagle okay so we can
just pick like beagle from here and all
fast like some random dog ran a picture
of a beagle and then I can copy this
image and then I can go into here and
paste this image so it's from like the
dog breed API and then all I need to do
is just run this a BS code it might take
a little bit because a little bit
because it's downloading the image and
it's gonna convert the basically just
this just a test script that feeds it to
this API that I've already made that
we're gonna build today
and Elvita as a JSON and then all it
does is OH print the results so you can
see at the bottom
it confidently predict Spiegel is like
the most the breed that thinks it's the
most close to but also guess like some
other breeds but it has like a much
lower confidence so you can see like
this one has a 60% confidence for beagle
but the other ones have like a 14% so
this is essentially what we're gonna be
building today so now we can head back
to the slides so we're going to be
talking about how do we actually
classify dogs and cats so it's really
easy for us as humans if we look at like
the image on there we can easily tell
like the one below the left is a cat and
the one on the right is a dog but if you
think about how we know this it's
because at some point in our lives
probably like when we're like 4 or 5
years old maybe our teacher or like our
parents told us like oh this is a cat
and this is a dog and then throughout
our entire lives we've been seeing like
a lot of cats and dogs and we've
essentially been trained to know that
like oh this is a cat and this is a dog
and that's why we're so confident in
knowing like and being able to tell the
difference but we can also see that
let's say you don't really know dog
breeds that much so if I show this
example you might not know that the one
on the left is an Alaskan Malamute and
the one on the right is a Siberian Husky
even though they look really similar but
I can actually train you to do this by
telling you essentially that like an
Alaskan Malamute looks like a husky but
it has like a darker fur where Siberian
Husky has like it looks the same but has
lighter fur so if I just told you this
and then show you some more images you
could also be trained essentially to
tell the differences between them so you
learning like that way so how do we
actually teach machines how to train and
classify dogs and cats well we can do
the same thing we did ourselves we just
trained the machine to actually learn
the differences between them so we can
do this by essentially giving our image
or machine like our computer or neural
net a lot of images and examples of the
different dog breeds so I can actually
learn like we did to tell the
differences between them so how does
this all work well the basic high-level
idea is that you'll have an image so in
this case it's just an image of a dog
but it'll be fed into this black box
which we'll call the machine for now and
if this black box outputs the
classifications and what it is so in our
case we're gonna be quickly classifying
between like a dog and cat or other and
I call this a black box because this is
like not a super technical talk on deep
learning but uh
you can think about a black box just
because you know the inputs to it which
is like an image and the outputs of it
which is like what the classified image
is and this technique is essentially
called deep learning and why it works so
well is because this black box because
you know the inputs and because you know
the outputs doesn't mean that you know
how it actually got there there's no
like it's a nonlinear transformation so
you don't really know it's kind of like
a brain in that sense it doesn't really
there's no way to actually trace back
how you actually got to a dog from the
image so you've heard the word deep
learning and you've heard machine
learning but how are they actually
different you might be asking that
so with traditional machine learning you
have to do is something called a feature
extraction so what that means is like
let's say you have a dataset do you want
to figure out oh what's the best
vacation places in the world that you
want to what are the best vacation spots
in the world do you want to travel to
some of your features there could be or
you're like features you can think of as
important factors but some of your
features might be like climate or like
how much the plane ticket is to that
like specific location so those are like
really concrete examples of my features
and also with machine learning you'll
need to figure out which of those
features are and you also need to figure
out the classification algorithm because
machine learning there's like a bunch of
different algorithms you can use and
you'll need to figure out like which
one's the best and gives you the optimal
results and where this kind of falls
apart is for images for machine learning
like if you look at this picture of a
dog right now like can anyone tell me
like what are the features that make up
a dog right it's like not as concrete as
obvious as something like for travel
destinations like weather which is like
really really concrete so are the
features like the pixels on its nose is
that what makes up a dog is it the color
of its like fur is that these groups of
pixels like this is where unless you're
like a PhD or an expert in image
analysis you probably wouldn't be able
to tell me that
so this is where deep learning comes in
it helps a lot so with deep learning you
actually it actually does something
called feature learning so with deep
learning it'll figure out automatically
or I should say automagically like what
are the important features that make up
a dog so it'll automatically not on
itself and it'll do the classification
itself as well so this is where it's
really really useful because for images
you don't really know what the features
are so there's actually a few several
different deep neural nets we can use
but for this
I'd want to get too deep into it but
we're gonna use something called a
convolutional convolutional neural
network so CNN and we're choosing this
because it's really good in industry
it's being proven industry by like PhDs
the PG professors and stuff like that
that it's really really good for image
classification and I don't want to get
into too much detail but you can think
of a CNN drill net it's like it just has
a bunch of layers and I'll process your
image to the layers and they'll
transform the image each time to
actually get the output so now I want to
get into like a traditional like machine
learning or jatis data science workflow
so this is essentially what we're gonna
be doing today but this can also be
applied like to like basically 99% of
data science workflows so the first step
is always data exploration so when you
have like some sort of problem you're
trying to figure out like some business
logic you want to figure out your data
set essentially so that's like one of
the main things you want to figure out
you want to create your data set the
second most important thing is you also
want to you might want to transform your
data so let's say you have a bunch of
images they're all gonna be different
sizes resolutions so you might want to
transform them and crop them all to be
like two 24 by 2 24 pixels as an example
and the final thing is you want to do
data sanitization because a lot of your
data sets you might have like corrupts
or bad data so you want to make sure
that that data set doesn't like skew up
those like that bad corrupt data doesn't
skew up you're screwed ski up the
training of your models you want to like
clean that data essentially so once you
actually have your data set you've
cleaned it and verified it the next step
is training so we're gonna be training
for example us we're gonna be doing our
training our model to detect them
dog and cat breeds so training can be
essentially split up into three
different things you'll need a training
script probably in Python because it's
the best language we're gonna be needing
some sort of compute power because if
you're trained this on your laptop like
you don't really want to wait like a
week so like train your model and just
to find out you did something wrong and
then you have to wait like another week
to train it you're probably gonna want
to train it in the cloud in some sort of
like really powerful computer or machine
in the cloud that will take like instead
of a week it might take like an hour and
then finally we're gonna be tuning our
model so just because we trained it and
got like a relatively good accuracy we
can actually like tune our model to make
even better so it might instead of like
let's say 80% accuracy of detecting cats
and dog breeds we can maybe get like 90%
is an example and then the last part is
once you actually have your dataset and
you trained your model to be like really
really good accuracy and you're ready to
like have that model perform out there
in the world you want to start
influencing so infants things basically
having making the models of service so
other people can use it to essentially
categorize their own pet breeds so to do
this we need to productionize our codes
so we have a jupiter notebook before but
we want to convert it's like a Python
file like a Python module that can be
reusable we'll want to like package our
model so a lot of these times we want to
save our model into the cloud and yeah
because of this we can push this into
the cloud and then finally you'll have
some sort of application whether it's
like a smart phone app or like a web app
or web API and then all it does is you
can pass in like an image of a dog and
it'll return the breed of the dog cool
so let's move on to the data exploration
phase for our pet detector so we're
gonna be using a dataset called the
Oxford pet dataset so it's like open
source dataset made by I think Oxford
University and it has this data set has
37 categories so you can think about is
like 37 different dog and cat breeds and
in the each of these categories there's
around like 200 images for each class so
I think me 200 images of like one beta
dog and one wave cat
and while I like this data set a lot is
because it's mostly fun just because you
get a look at cute like dogs and cats
all day so who can't complain and
there's also I just want to point out
this Lee initiative from Microsoft to
also publish many of these open source
datasets on something called as your
open datasets so that anybody can just
find them so this is where you can also
find the oxford pet dataset as well
cool so on the data exploration phase
now we pick the data set and now we want
to actually like check the dataset
explore and make sure that it's like I
mentioned the first step that it's like
clean and sanitary and do any
transformations we need so there's many
different rate tools to do this one of
the most popular tools that data
scientists use to do data exploration is
something called Jupiter notebooks so
Jupiter notebooks is really good because
it's really easy to set up there's like
minimal installs you need to do and it's
really really good for
typing and experimenting because you
have to run each line of code at a time
instead of having to run the entire file
and I'm gonna use something called we're
gonna use BS code for that because
there's now Jupiter notebook support and
vias code so you can actually like in
the screenshot on the right you can see
that there's a full-fledged super
notebook in BS code and where there's a
super powerful is that you can actually
do like a lot of IDE stuff in vs inside
Jupiter notebooks where you went normal
you have so you would have things like
autocomplete you have things like
debugging variable Explorer stuff like
that but rather than talk about it I'll
do a quick demo of our data exploration
phase so let me just go ahead up here
and back into vs code so if we go I have
this Jupiter notebook file I've loaded
I'll have a link at the end of this talk
about like how you can do this - on
github but I have this Jupiter notebook
and here I've loaded I've downloaded the
data set onto my computer but now one
thing I want to check is I actually want
to look at the data so I can run the
cell for example and the cell
essentially is it'll get a sample of
each of the categories in the data set
so it should hopefully plot in that
matplotlib so you can see here it has
all of the each of the 37 categories and
just picks like a random image from
those so these are all that I guess pet
breeds that is gonna be training and
also another thing we can see here is it
does some data analysis to make sure
that none of these the datasets like
clean and there's no like corrupt data
in that sense cool so now we have to see
that and we can go back into our slides
so now that we verified that now that we
download their data set and loaded that
data set into vs code and into our
troopers notebook now we can do now we
can go on to the training step so the
training step is usually one of the
longest steps because you have to do you
have to wait for all the passes of
training but so with deep learning it by
nature it requires a lot a lot of data
to actually tune and train your model to
something that's super accurate and
because of this it also requires huge
computational resources because images
are like a lot bigger in terms of data
the compared to like
just text our numbers so you'll need a
lot of computation for that so also like
I mentioned with our Oxford pet data set
there was only around 200 images for
breed and that's definitely not enough
usually you want like its traditional
deep loading you want like let's say
like 10,000 images per category so 200
is definitely not enough so we're gonna
have to find some workaround so there's
some possible solutions for working with
small data sets the most obvious one is
that oh we can just always get more data
sets
oh sorry more data for our data set so
we have a larger data set and as much as
I'd love going around taking pictures
going around campus taking pictures of
people's cats and dogs and classifying
them it's definitely not a good use of
my time
so one we want to find the solutions
like a lot more easier and quick I just
want to mention like throw this out here
there's also like k-fold
cross-validation it's just some like
sort of mathematical way to do it but
it's like really really complex so you
don't have we don't want to do that and
the last thing which we're kind of
interested in is we're gonna be reusing
one solutions reusing pre-trained models
so it's a technique called transfer
learning so what this means is we take
some existing model that's been trained
by like PhD or professors in the world
that's been trained to some sort of
general image classification like some
sort of general problem and we're gonna
take that pre trained model and actually
tune it towards what we need so we're
gonna pick that because it's the easiest
to do and it doesn't require any more
data that we need and it's really really
fast so like I mention with transfer
learning it's a really popular technique
it just takes you can just take an
existing real net and then transfer it
like just modify it to where it's what
you need and how that works is like I
mentioned in the CNN slide of how
convolutional nets work you can imagine
it like a bunch of layers and all we're
doing is we're just retraining the last
layer of the neural net because the last
layer is what actually determines what
the classification is for the image so
we're gonna be using a pre trained
neural net called mobile net and mobile
net is something that's used in the
industry it's created by some professors
and it's already trained on things like
objects that's just like cars trucks
dogs cats which is why we're using it
for but we're gonna actually we're going
to modify it so that it can train
between the different dog breeds and cat
breeds
and this is just training the last fully
connected layer so we can do this by we
can go back to vs code real quick and we
can show I can show the training step so
this is still in my Jupiter notebook on
BS code and here I can see I run my
training script so we can see like I
mentioned we're using mobile net as our
base base pre-trained model to actually
tune towards training for pet breeds and
I just give it's like some parameters
like my image directory where my dataset
is and then some more important things
are learning rate which is what I'll
talk about later but learning rate is
something you choose as a data scientist
to figure out like it's a parameter of
your neural net and finally I trained it
for 500 steps just just a show see what
kind of accuracy we can get so I ran
this earlier because I don't want to you
guys to sit through this training but
you can see after 500 steps we get
around a test accuracy of 78% which is
pretty good and we got this in 8 minutes
and for context when this dataset first
came out around like 7 years ago it's
like the best researchers in the world
with PhDs with unlimited compute power
the best they were able to get was I
think 59 percent and that was probably
over like many days of training and we
were able to get 78 percent in just
eight minutes which is like pretty cool
if you think about how far the fields of
deep learning has advanced in just those
seven years so 78 percent slike pretty
good it's pretty good for what we need
but I think we can do like a lot better
so we're gonna do something called a
hyper parameter tuning so let me just go
back to the slides so like I mentioned
after you train your after you train
your model for the first time there's
you can also tune your model to get a
little bit better accuracy for your
model so we're gonna talk about hyper
parameter tuning so like I mentioned
before we're gonna we're gonna there's a
thing called learning rate which you
probably saw earlier so learning rate is
something that you choose as a data
scientist for the training part of your
model and you can imagine learning rate
as how big of a step your model tow
takes towards the optimal goal so the
optimal goal obviously is like 100
percent accuracy and this is something
you pick as the data scientist so if you
pick too small of a number it might
never reach your goal because you're
just taking too small step but if you
take if you pick too big of a learning
rate it might just overshoot your goal
and again you
reach your goal so you want to find like
a good balance in the middle and usually
as a data scientist you have like some
intuition of like what generally the
number is but you don't it's really hard
to figure out what the actual number
like the actual number you should feed
into the model to get the optimal
accuracy is so you don't really want to
go like one way to solve this is you
just trial an error like a bunch of
numbers but that could take like like I
mentioned training takes a long time so
that could take like even weeks or days
for each of these trainings so we're
gonna be using something called Azure
machine learning service which is offers
like a surface in the cloud to actually
do this for you automatically
so with Azure machine learning service
actually boost your data sense
productivity so it's just like a pip
install you just do on your computer and
it comes with like pre trained models
and you can also as preaching
classification algorithms and you can
easily like deploy your things to the
cloud so the thing we're gonna be using
from Azure machine learning service
right now is the increasing your rate of
experimentation so what this means is my
convention we're gonna be testing
treating a hyper parameter for learning
rate and learning rate like each of
these runs and each of these experiments
could take a long time maybe like a few
days so you don't want to wait you don't
want to do them sequentially you can do
them actually pair in parallel with
Azure machine learning service so it
just scales up to what you need so you
can run like let's say a hundred
different values at the same time and
I'll just all run in same time it'll
pick the best one for you and finally
what we'll need in the next step later
is the production Eisinger machine
learning service so here you can
actually easily deploy and manage your
models of the cloud but I'll talk about
that later and here's some other things
that our machine learning service does
but we're getting mostly focus on the
first point which is the simplified
hyper parameter tuning which we're gonna
do right now so let's go back to vs code
again and if I go into my notebook oops
if I go into my notebook
so my later cells here's where I set up
the agile machine learning so here's
where like I login with my credentials
and then here I upload my files
essentially to the cloud and here's
where the code is for actually doing the
hyper parameter tuning so the server
isn't as machine learning for a hyper
parameter tuning is called a hyper drive
so this is the main code that does it so
you can see so I have a pip installed
the azure machine-learning SDK but here
I create
estimator from tensorflow so this is
what actually has my model and I give it
the same training script that I ran
locally that got me that 80 or so that's
78% on my local computer I give it to
the estimator which will train it in the
cloud and here's the important code that
we need so like I mentioned we were
going to be experimenting with learning
rate so instead of just giving it a
value and testing it manually we're
gonna say we're gonna randomly test
values and a log uniform between
negative 15 to negative 3 so just pick a
bunch of these values and test them and
finally the most important thing a
really really cool thing is we'll have
an early termination policy so I'll show
you a little bit more detail of this in
a bit but essentially what it's saying
is that since it's doing a bunch of
these runs in parallel if it'll say if
it's at exit run if it's doing an
experiment and it picks some sort of
learning rate and that learning rate is
ganks your accuracy accuracy from that
learning rate is actually less than 15%
of the most the best learning rate
you've seen so sorry have the best
accuracy you've seen so far then just
kill it because it's kind of like a lost
cause at that point and you don't to
waste your compete power so this is
where Azure machine learning service can
actually like save you a lot of money
because you're not wasting compute power
unlike runs that you know we're gonna
fail so this is where actually start
running it into the cloud and for the
sake of time again I've done I've
already done this a little bit earlier
so you can see this is the experiment
when you actually run when I run the
cell in vs code it generates this
experiment in the cloud and I've logged
into Azure the azure web portal and you
can see after just only like 200 runs
with like these are the different
learning rates I've tried you can see
that I've get like some of the best
models of gun have around 90% accuracy
so we've already boosted our accuracy
from the 78% initially that I've trained
on my computer to 90% just by
essentially almost doing nothing I just
hooked this up to a sh machine learning
surface and tell them to do it to pick
the best hyper parameter for me so
that's really really cool that we just
essentially got extra 10% accuracy for
doing nothing and like I mentioned the
early termination stuff that you can see
like some of these runs didn't complete
and this is where the early termination
policy that was talking about so it's
not that the accuracy was
like so much worse than this like 90%
one so he realizes like there's no point
continuing you might as well just give
up and then reuse that compute power
that you already are paying for for like
actual like runs that will actually
generate good results so you can see
yeah I got around like some of the best
models I get around like 90% now as you
can see the 0.9 one and the freight and
that's the accuracy so from here I can
actually I'll take like the best I'll
take the best run so I can actually find
like you know as machine learning
service will tell me which learning rate
actually gave me the best friend so I'll
actually take that model that gives me
that 90% accuracy so let's go back to
the slides real quick so then now now
that we've actually did the hyper
parameter tuning what's this loads we
need to start production izing our model
so this is so now that we have a really
really good model let's go back here now
we have a real really good model we want
to actually productionize it so we can
push it into the cloud so the others can
actually call the service to actually do
that pet detection that they want so to
do this we want to make a python module
since right now we just have a jupiter
notebook and it's kind like messy code
we want to create - like we want to
refactor it's a good code and to do this
again we can use to just to do code
again so we have this really cool
feature inside the notebook editor that
you put Jupiter notebook editor that I
just showed you that automatically
converts your jupiter notebook code into
python code and once it's in python code
you have full access to all your
traditional like python editing
environment and vs code and all your
good like we're factoring stuff so you
can do things such as like we're factor
variable explorer data explorer you can
you have access again to auto completion
so again i can show you that real quick
in yes code so this is my notebook
this is button up top at the top right
and it says comfort and save to a python
script so if i click that it will
generate essentially this file so you
can see it's the same code so if i
scroll to the top of the super notebook
it's literally the same code but now
like you see the CD images you'll see
like a CD images believe up here
somewhere but
it just generates the same yes sir you
see the images right here so yeah it
generates literally the same code but
now in a Python file so normally as a
data scientist if you want to start
production Eisinger could you normally
have to copy and paste all these cells
into a new Python file but because of
this functionality we can now just
automatically do for you and save you
the time and once you actually have it
in this generated Python file you can
start using like some of the refactoring
tools such as like exporting or
extracting variables extracting methods
and then you have a final script that
essentially does does everything you
need in much cleaner code cool so now
the last part is we want to start now
that we've actually cleaned up record we
want to actually deploy our code or our
model and code to the cloud so this is
where the deployment part of machine
layer learning service comes in so to
deploy we're gonna actually do this
again in vs code I can see there's like
a common theme of everything can be done
right now in vs code but we're gonna be
using the as machine learning service
extension which also is again free and
because of this I can login to my own
account that I used previously and I can
do things such as like sub made
experiments which I just did before but
the more important two things I want to
do are register my model so that model
that I already that I did the hyper
parameter training with I got that 90
percent I can actually register that
model and deploy that model to the cloud
so others can use it so you can see if I
go back to one last time 50s code I have
the agile machine learning service right
here this is the extension and you can
see that here's the endpoints and all I
need all I need to do is deploy service
and because I actually ran that
experiment in the cloud you can see the
model that generated that safe the best
model is already here so all I needed to
do is just deploy service click
registered model and then it'll pick one
of the models from here yeah so you can
see like here's some like the models
that were created but I just save like
the best one that got me that 90% and
it's already in a ml so I just need to
select the right one but again for the
sake of time I've already deployed this
which is why I saw in the beginning I
can already start detecting model I can
already run this test script that pings
this endpoint to get me the dog breed
cool so I guess yeah just a wrapper
let's just talk about everything we've
done today and how you can also apply
this workflow to your own data science
needs so in review
like I was mentioning the machine
learning workflow we started with data
exploration so for us we found the
Oxford pet dataset and we downloaded
that inter machine and then we actually
did some we loaded into our Jupiter
notebook and then we actually cleaned up
that code cleaned up the data and
actually saw like on that map on that
graph like some of the samples of the
images we have the next step is so yeah
we use this we use the pet dataset and
Jupiter notebook for that the next step
is we did training so we had our
training script again in our Jupiter
notebook and vs code and our compute we
did as well and then finally the tuning
is the hyper parameter tuning so that's
where we got that 79 and a 78 percent
from our regular training script and
compute but the tuning made it I'll jump
all the way to 90 percent and again we
for the compute and tuning we use the
magic machine learning service and then
finally we did infant sing so once we
actually had our model and we trained it
with our good data we want to
productionize that to the cloud so again
we used vs code for this by converting
our Jupiter notebook into a Python file
and then from that python file we were
able to do a lot of refactoring and then
from that and then we were able to
deploy that code and model to the cloud
with the agile machine learning service
extension that I just showed so I
uploaded that to the cloud and that was
using adverting Linux service and we
have our application and the final thing
is that we can see that all of this was
done inside the PS code and the Python
extension 4 vs code which is all
cross-platform open-source and
completely free so yeah so what's next
well you can actually build your own pet
detector just like I did so here's like
a link to the github repo I'll have this
I'll post this up later or so you can
take pictures but you can train it to
whatever you want so for us we did pet
detector but maybe you want to do like a
Pokemon detector or something you can do
that we can try out the vs coach cheaper
to support today so something like the
duper notebook stuff I showed inside vs
code that's all already available it
just came out in October so our team
worked on that so it'd be really cool if
you guys check it out and for more
information
about the Python extension which is
where actually the Jupiter notebook
support is here's a link for that and
finally the last one is if you want to
learn a little bit more but as machine
learning service where we did some of
the hyper parameter tuning are deploying
to the cloud and we have that yeah thank
you for your time and yeah if you have
any questions you can reach out to me on
Twitter or email and we're also in a
Microsoft booth yes code booth right
outside thank you thank you Jeff EMU do
we have any questions could you go into
a little bit more detail about how
you're able to sanitize the images and
more specifically how you were able to
verify that the images were properly
sanitized because you know first I want
to sit through all thousands of images
well so I kind of like cheated a little
bit here in the sense that so for like a
since this is Oxford pet data set so
it's from Oxford it's like a reputable
it's like something reputable so I
already kind of knew that it was clean
so I don't really have to go through the
cleaning of it but one thing I did just
to make sure that there was like no like
bad values is I just printed out like I
just picked like sample images I just
randomly picked images from the data set
and printed it and make sure that like
oh like for example this is like the
right picture for like the right breed
something like that but mostly I kind of
shoot it in the sense that I knew that
it's awesome fit dataset a lot of people
use it and from the University so they
already they basically said they already
cleaned it for us so we don't do that
but sometimes if you were trying to do
some like training from scratch and
you'll have your own dataset you would
have to manually do this yourself like
maybe with Python code or something but
yeah it's a it's a very good talk so for
the small datasets when you're picking
between K full validation and transfer
learning how do you decide which way to
go well for the sake of this talk it was
like something I just want to show
something basic but um the reason I did
transfer learning is because transfer
learning essentially you can you already
guaranteed to get good results because
you're already using a pre-existing
model that's already good you're just
trying to tune it towards what we need
we're capable across validation this is
like a little bit more technical but
we're capable cross validation works
better is let's say you have I mean I
guess you can also apply that k-fold
cross-validation with the transfer
learning but
across validations I guess better when
you have I guess a little bit more data
in that sense because what crazy fool
cross validation how you can think of it
how it works is basically randomize your
data set each time so then to your model
it looks like it's a new data set each
time right so that's basically how
capable cross validation works but in
practice we want to just want do
something easy and k-fold
cross-validation requires like a lot
more coding it's not like that and it
requires like a lot more runs
essentially so we did transfer me
because we only had to do like you saw
we only did it only took 8 minutes to do
because we already had an existing model
and also we didn't need to do it anymore
essentially we didn't need to do any
more coding to do it so we just pick
something a little super easy for our
needs but there are definitely times
where table across validation will help
you more so is there any minimum data
size limit for the transfer learning
process it's definitely like a
heuristics thing so it depends like how
complex your data is so like maybe since
we're detecting pet breeds for example
like the pets are like kind of like dogs
are like pretty similar like in looks I
guess by peer detecting I guess like
some different objects like maybe I
don't know like a chair in like a car
I'll give you an example I am working on
a similar project for wild cats okay and
for some of the species we have very
very small features that so we're trying
to use transforming and figuring that
out hmm well if like for that it's all
like again heuristics there's no like
one number just like with the thing I
said with learning rate there's no like
one number that's the best but the thing
I would do is I would just try it do it
like essentially trial and error like
for the days that you have right now
I'll just try it and if you have
decently like I would say if you have
over 70% accuracy then you can probably
keep doing it but if you have like below
70 percent accuracy this is just like my
opinion but if you have below 70%
accuracy maybe you start like doing some
other techniques like maybe capable
cross-validation or other techniques to
help boost your accuracy yeah but as a
lot of it is like case by case basis
yeah this might be slightly tangential
but does Venus code currently offer
support for pygame modules
pygame I'm not I'm also not too sure
because I mostly work on the data
science delight of it but um I would
assume like I know our our Python like
the core extension team they have it
basically have like support for
everything so I would assume yes yeah I
would definitely double-check but I'm
pretty sure it has
yeah hey yeah thank you so much we're
gonna be in a booth like right outside
right beside the num focusone so if you
have any more questions you want to ask
or anything else really there's a Python
or like is our vs code feel free to come
out yeah thank you
[Applause]
you